hello guys I'm Craig and I'm seeing a
lot of Cassidy Lerman you can follow her
on Instagram the only social media thing
she has I mean I have others I don't use
them she doesn't use them and I go to
her Instagram all the time do you
Oh before I go to sleep it's the best
thing to go look at I woke up and I want
okay then yeah I do a lot of
visualization and make sure you'll be
back in my life development I think that
just by the event is the worst month
attraction I make have to be a while ago
at a comedy joint or something like that
yeah I was with Anita and she was like
you gotta go talk to this girl does that
happen that is kind of what happened and
then yeah I figure out the surveillance
to you on camera camera no doesn't did
it and then she did and she came on yeah
no I was I was keeping yeah she was
smart I was paranoid because I was
working is this okay I forgot if we're
gonna do this we'll do it for real I saw
you across the room I'm like okay okay
and then I said that people think I'm
like smooth with women too like this is
exactly actually the Dayman really bad
you saw me really I saw her awesome and
I was like like wow I'd like that girl
has such a beautiful smile you guys
talker I'm like no I don't think so
that's what I need it was like I'm gonna
go sit next to them or even sighs wear
special shoes is trying to get us to
like October
oh I'm so good at it you can do it yeah
yeah it worked out perfectly well an
hour an hour buddies anyway enough
beating around the bush fire to the
caribbean dead men tell no tales
Cassidy is not seeing any of the
trailers for this so let's just watch
the extended TV spot together oh okay
cool you ready for this maybe we just
number five what is this at this one I
am okay
[Music]
pirates having said the disease for
generations so I felt eliminate them all
decks borrow curry to me my revenge
if you will just AA person race tomorrow
does not require such three the only one
I'm looking for trouble
[Music]
I did not believe in there you're not
feeling fine
stop monkey
[Music]
ah no it's not that at all I think it
looks really fun I told you to I mean I
think that they're always good really
gonna know how would you know I don't
like the fourth one okay I don't really
remember the first one not as the reason
why I mean I just think my job is still
it's really done Johnny had not
generally that's amazing yeah well I
mean I I loved in Papa they knew Orlando
Bloom are boys but yeah I'm using a
little bit he was so good oh I can't
pinpoint where I stand out here from he
was so brilliant enough well just like
French Frankie
well the plot of this one from what I
gathered from the trailer that came out
a while ago yeah I got a facial trailer
that is Javier Bardem with some pie the
Jack Sparrow when he was a youth worked
for so we saw a young Jack there for a
second and then some Jack did something
where he ended up getting cursed so he's
after Jack and blames him and then he's
like he's out to get Jack Sparrow and
kill em okay he must have gotten that
from another trailer because I did not
get it me oh yeah I'm not sure could you
tell me a little lose to that but the
other trailer makes it a lot clearer
like like what the plot is of that yeah
I don't know exactly an Orlando Bloom
was in like a snippet of the like a
brief second and and one of the TV slots
so early in it yeah the other two are
like what Keira Knightley on line a
little more work exactly what they want
exactly
well done it it's a fun [ __ ] movie I
think there's no fun there's a bed do
you think I just think pirates are so
much fun the dresses were fun Iceland
yeah like it's always good well I think
you know it's gotten bad with the last
one no oh come on
I mean Ranger Ty's Penelope Cruz was in
everything yes tonight was a hot woman I
just remember like vaguely a hot yeah
the top it was a
instead of a boring film but I love the
first two a lot and I think the first
one's been one of the best movie theater
experiences I've ever had in my entire
you really yeah oh gosh sightings it
dawned on me when I was watching the
first tyrunt's movie when I was watching
Jack Sparrow going holy [ __ ] with Johnny
Depp a guy in Edward Scissorhands was
joined up the guy Johnny Bravo like to
give all these movies I've seen I was
like I can't believe this guy can
transform that much I know I want to
love him so much you know what I mean
I've always loved them and now I want to
hate him but why why do you want to hate
him trying to like bad news though
because he could be hit amber hurt yeah
we don't know that I mean just because
most evident the main reason a lot that
you know it's a touchy situation I gotta
love him so much I love my whole life
who doesn't well Johnny got well maybe
uh maybe she had it coming okay it's a
reason she deserved it not
I don't really thank you I don't see no
I probably the craziest news I've ever
heard for that and when Tim Burton broke
up his wife yeah oh my god what my
Buddhist optimistic Thailand and a
support my name is almost do people
wrinkles just like boom boom because
they haven't been working together
lately that's it they're losing sided I
know you join down gaining weight and
everything yeah no job please bring the
photos oh you mean this Oh get in here
it looks like a character Lee's here is
going Amber Heard thing oh my god yeah I
know you know that's world buying oh my
love that photo to be looks like a
rapist I think normally there's better
photos of Johnny Dunne has been playing
an unfortunate yeah mom she looks the
lovely individual well who knows
I don't know besides that I think we can
play people's mistakes and their
personal life to the side how can you
enjoy Pirates of the Caribbean you you
hate the art when the person doesn't
deserve it or do you separate the to
personalize and professionalized I don't
know and we don't really know for sure B
how do we know he did it
and then he's just like yeah you [ __ ]
deserved what if you would like to rock
you made a mistake and you he's aware of
that you know I mean this helps you
think I don't know enough about this I
can't really like say mama knowing me I
mean so much controversy she did she did
donate a million dollars that she got
the settlement to a charity I'm just
saying I know you'll achieve everyone
has that about women which he didn't
need the publicity because it's just a
publicity when you you know say
something like that people are like good
for you girl they're like she's probably
aligned we were anything but I don't
know why except that's my call is just
negative negative attention yeah
no one does that knowingly I know what
it's like to be a woman art I thought so
myself know like damn he knows what yeah
woman he's so confident to get that sex
change to become a man that's exactly
right he said to me I was like no I was
born like I know you believe your
boredom and I was like why we have to
say hi you're harder than he was like no
physically born I know you believe you
were physically meant to be a man okay
we can talk on that that's a whole other
video nothing to do my area because it's
such you'll be happy yeah will the wrong
go I can do okay her join up in an
interview in any interview ever yeah
yeah I could do I could do a giant
impression me okay
this video was only about a Johnny Depp
yeah yeah my giant F impression for you
understand it it's involved from a man
who he takes his time when he talks is
like he said somebody was facing that
super deep Amina both an end to being
done
super simple right oh yeah all right
I'll get him I tried as I showed warmed
up the free camera okay all right
whoo I'm Jimmy do when I first read the
screenplay for him
Ringo half way through the script that
realized I'm playing the lizard and from
there the character just sort of evolved
[Music]
long time ago yeah the Rangers oh he
does say intelligent things that's just
when I've seen like a few moments around
life you sounds like you do it face
because it takes a lot of pauses genius
yeah you sing well yeah you really
evaluate anyway yeah he's a deep danger
yeah I like it you ponder okay yeah yeah
Johnny
Jimmy I will stop my mouth oh I'm just
so guilty that's alright that's alright
don't worry about no more that will only
get a few day common maybe a lot we all
love Johnny Depp we're all going to
watch Pirates of the Caribbean at the
end of the day despite what we think of
Johnny Depp Magnus's we're not going to
go anti Johnny Depp protest outside the
feeder we're all going to be there we
like the trailer that's what yeah well I
think our guard on the reason job yaar
oh he is amazing oh it's holding hands
and everybody does I'm excited
oh yeah just for that he's a great
villain and anything he's a villain
don't double cha the movie oh my god I
didn't realize there was anything but my
mom is Wow your about it
like I know true no but like he like
really changes with you troll oh yeah
totally I mean even if he's a bad guy
he does he does a different kind of bad
guy every time I think there's always a
different motivation yeah it is in his
mannerisms his body language his speech
pattern changes yes I think so it's like
it's easy to typecast in his hobby right
name is always a bad guy but he's a
different kind of bad guy every time
because I don't think we when he plays
bad guys he views himself as a bad guy
well it's not generic yeah that's the
best part is like be tormented weird
zakharik it comes from a good place
where you almost love him yeah he can
that's true I can tell in G
gravitational yeah yeah when the officer
for no country said okay so good I know
and what's the boy I'm more like the boy
and the love and training event is
useful Oh wrong with that right
give me the first a heart are sexy we're
getting an entire movie you know that
sweetly yeah hard are really teammate
leave us no real know the pg-13 350
million dollar budget I'm gonna make it
harder anyway subscribe to the real
reason enough died a political
controversy whatever a topper haven't
yet happiness keep it like follow the
lovely beautiful Cassidy to Letterman
Instagram yes where you'll see that I
have like all the post so not true oh my
god you've never gone where we will post
yeah yeah and then they you came from
the real rejects they often say that say
Greg brought me here you can only find
her bikini photos on any bikini photos I
know
[Laughter]
and oh I want to give a shout out to be
the first person that requested this
Matthew Holmes Sherlock Holmes is less
appreciated brother goodbye